on est très heureux d'accueillir rené
troccaz l'ambassadeur rené troccaz qui
actuellement consul général de france à
jérusalem est est en quelque sorte qui
joue le rôle d'ambassadeur à jérusalem
et notamment dans la relation avec les
palestiniens comme comme vous le savez
et cette réunion a été évidemment très
importante elle était calé bien avant
mais elle se tient quasiment un mois
jour pour jour après la journée du 10
mai dernier qui a été marqué vous vous
en souvenez par de très durs
affrontements sur l'esplanade des
mosquées et dans la soirée par le
déclenchement par le hamas deux des
premières salves de roquettes
merci monsieur le consul hier à 2-2 vous
êtes rendus disponibles pour cette
audition je sais que cette période est
difficile pour vous car évidemment vous
êtes un observateur est un acteur très
attentif dans dans cette crise où vous
avez vécu au coeur de cet embrasement
aussi soudain que meurtrier je rappelle
qu'il ya eu de nombreux morts de chaque
côté et bien évidemment nous allons vous
écouter avec la plus grande attention
d'une part sur le déroulement de la
crise les responsabilités et les
significations profondes c'est ça qui
nous intéresse mais aussi sur l'avenir
du cessez-le-feu du 21 mai qui nous
paraît une fois de plus particulièrement
fragile avant tout je veux saluer votre
action nous nous connaissons bien vous
m'avez accueilli à chypre et vous avez
fait un travail extraordinaire pour le
compte de notre pays à chypre et vous
êtes maintenant un habitué des postes
sensibles et compliqué ce qui est un
signe de vos hautes compétences et de
l'attachement que le qe vous portent
bien sûr et donc je veux au passage
salué à la fois votre action et celle de
votre équipe dans une circonscription
diplomatiques particulièrement
par difficile vous veillez bien sûr à la
sécurité de nos concitoyens
mais je rappelle que vous êtes aussi
administrateur des domaines nationaux en
terre-sainte vous nous en direz
peut-être un mot vous assurer la
protection des communautés religieuses
et vous entretenez je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure notre relation diplomatique avec
l'autorité palestinienne ce qui n'est
pas une mince affaire
en effet votre circonscription s'étend
de la jordanie a ôté ritter de gaza donc
nous serions intéressés à ce que vous
nous présentiez une analyse des
événements et les prémices du reste
d'une spirale de violence qui ont
certainement des causes multiples on a
pu imposer on a pu imputer la montée des
tensions à jérusalem à l'accélération du
processus de colonisation notamment dans
le quartier de cheikh jarrah à jérusalem
est la même ou des procédures
d'expulsion vise des résidents
palestiniens qui ont bénéficié de
logements entre 1948 et 1967 pendant
l'administration jordanienne et qui font
donc l'objet de procédures d'expulsion
ces procédures semble avoir été renvoyé
à une date ultérieure vous nous direz ce
qu'il en est il y a bien évidemment
d'autres causes liées notamment à
l'impasse politique du processus de paix
entre israéliens et palestiniens
est ce que vous partagez le constat sur
lequel il n'y a plus de perspective ni
de volonté pour avancer vers la solution
à deux états solution qui je le rappelle
est toujours soutenue par la france et
ce à l'intérieur de frontières sûres et
reconnues sur la base des lignes du 4
juin 1967
y at il du reste une solution
alternative faut-il imaginer un seul
état et dans ce cas selon quelles
modalités
la formule employée par notre ministre
des affaires étrangères sur je cite le
risque d'apartheid n'est pas inédite
mais elle a fait réagir les autorités
israéliennes elle repose sur la crainte
d'une pérennisation d'une inégalité
entre des droits d'une part du côté des
israéliens et moins de droits du côté
des palestiniens
s'agissant du processus électoral la
situation semble se débloquer côté
israélien avec peut-être dans les
prochains jours
un événement majeur puisque il pourrait
on pourrait connaître un débouché à la
crise politique avec l'investiture par
la knesset d'une coalition qui réunit
yaïr lapid naftali bennett et mansour
abbas le chef du parti conservateur
islamistes là aussi vous nous direz où
nous en sommes aujourd'hui car les
événements se succèdent quasiment jour
par jour
en revanche côté palestinien une fois de
plus les législatives ont été reportées
par l'autorité palestinienne pour toutes
sortes de bonnes et peut-être mauvaises
raisons vous nous direz ce que vous
pensez d'une relance du procès du
processus électoral palestinien et nous
direz si c'est enfin possible
vous êtes déjà venu devant cette
commission donc vous savez comment nous
travaillons
nous allons vous entendre pendant un
quart d'heure et puis après je pense que
nous aurons quelques questions à vous
poser
malheureusement nous n'aurons pas un
sénateur qui s'occupe particulièrement
de cette affaire c'est gilbert roger qui
vous le savez soutien a causé des
palestiniens et il a il est
malheureusement hospitalisé enfin je
pense que son état est stationnaire
d'après les informations que j'ai pu
avoir mais on lui souhaite un prompt
rétablissement et je précise donc que
cette audition fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo qui va être retransmise
en direct sur le site internet du sénat
et que vous pourrez consulter à la
demande chez rené trop cacher consul
général vous avez maintenant la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
merci d'abord de vos mots aimables et je
suis extrêmement heureux sensible et je
me sur la responsabilité que ça
représente pour un reportage à france 2
d'être auditionnés à cette prestigieuse
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense du sénat
je vais essayer donc de vous présenter
les choses de la manière la plus
synthétique possible si on est derniers
événements d'abord un retour sur les
faits ensuite essayez d'entrevoir les
conséquences et peut-être de d'esquisser
ce que peuvent être les perspectives
pour la suite
j'ai bien noté par ailleurs monsieur le
président les les points que vous avez
soulevé dans votre exposé liminaire
donc je vous salue et toutes et tous
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
je vais essayer donc d'abord commencé en
revenant sur les faits qui se sont
produits et qui ont amené à la situation
dans laquelle nous nous trouvons ici et
que nous observons à jérusalem le les
éléments de contexte
il y en a sur lequel je ne m'étendrai
pas parce que je ne le suis pas
directement mais vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le président ce sont des
élections israéliennes
les quatrièmes élections en deux ans
avec toujours cette incertitude
électorale qui tient peut-être au mode
de scrutin qui est inspecteur
intégralement proportionnelle toujours
est il que là on semble s'acheminer
peut-être dimanche à la knesset à la
désignation d'une nouvelle majorité d'un
nouveau premier ministre
avec une un ensemble d'une majorité
extrêmement hétéroclites il faut bien le
dire puisque ça va à la fois du parti
yamina conquis par monsieur bennett dont
je comprends qu'ils pourraient être le
premier premier ministre de cette de
cette belle formation au parti ram qui
est un parti islamiste israélien en
passant par des partis de gauche comme
le merrell ces parties du sort voilà
mais enfin mon collègue ambassadeur à
tel-aviv pour en parler mieux que moi
donc ça c'est le premier élément de
contexte et bien évidemment ça pèse sur
le
la situation générale l inverse si je
puis dire là où il ya peut-être je ne
rappelais pas trop d'élections de
beaucoup d'élections côté draillard des
listes natif tous les six mois il ya
peut-être qu'il ya certainement une
pénurie de l'autre côté c'est à dire du
côté palestinien les dernières élections
législatives palestiniennes se sont
tenus en 2006 et ceux ci un an après la
mort d'arafat qui avait donc il y avait
eu des élections 2005 la désignation du
président abbas qu elle était élue au
suffrage universel depuis les élections
législatives en 2006 qui avait abouti à
la victoire du hamas
qu'a-t-on observée au cours des derniers
mois nous ici à jérusalem avec
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale nous avons suivi donc
cette fois ça suce électorale qui devait
se dérouler ce qu'il faut re et qui n'a
pas abouti et les élections ayant été
reportée sine aidiez ce qu'on peut
retenir c'est d'abord eux la moitié de
l'électorat palestinien
si les élections avaient bien eu lieu
aurait voté pour la première fois deux
sets c'est donc un électorat très jeune
la deuxième chose c'est qu'il y avait
une envie d'élections et de démocratie
genre propres heures d'abord le nombre
d'inscrits sur les listes électorales
93 % soit 10 points de plus qu'en 2006
et d'autre part le foisonnement des
listes électorales 36 et on a pu noter
au delà de ces chiffres
un véritable engouement pour la la chose
électorale
j'ajoute ces élections auraient eu le
mérite comme toute élection de re
légitimité l'autorité palestinienne qui
très honnêtement danse est maintenant
par décret et qui au fil du temps se
trouve de moins en moins légitime au
regard de sa propre opinion publique
tout ceci pour dire et ça s'en vont
peser sur la suite des événements
immédiatement après qu'il ya quand même
eu une frustration sourde mais forte
dans l'opinion palestinienne opinion
jeunes et qui n'a pas évoqué depuis 15
ans
la question je la borde tout de suite
que vous avez évoqué monsieur le
président de la relance du processus
électoral palestiniens bien sûr nous
sommes favorables à cette perspective
quand je dis nous c'est la france mais
l'union européenne également
disons les choses comme elles se
présentent après les événements de ces
dernières semaines
là où certains avaient quelques craintes
que le hamas ne gagne des élections là
honnêtement ce serait mentir que de ne
pas dire qu'il est au faîte de sa
popularité en ce moment donc ça c'est
quand même un élément à prendre en
considération la raison pour laquelle
les élections n'ont pas eu lieu qu'à la
raison qui a été invoquée c'est qu'à la
différence de 2005 et de 2006 les
palestiniens l'autorité palestinienne
n'a pas pu obtenir l'assurance
les israéliens eux le scrutin se
tiendrait également à jérusalem est
là aussi à votre précision sans rentrer
dans le détail ce que les palestiniens
pour être très clair attendait là où on
est à peu près 150 me les électeurs
inscrits à jérusalem-est sur une
population totale palestiniens de
jérusalem est qui est supérieur à 350
mille personnes c'est elle que en 2006 à
peu près 5000 personnes avaient voté il
pouvait mais bien d'avoir un peu moins
des gens avec les doigts de bureaux de
poste et font ce que les palestiniens
voulaient c'était que même
symboliquement on puisse avoir une
expression du vote interne et pas
seulement du vote électronique et
jérusalem est
voilà donc c'est l'argument qui a été
invoqué et qui a fait qu'effectivement
les élections parce que certains
commentateurs considèrent qu'il est
plein d'autres raisons d'une autre
nature par exemple l'incertitude du
parti dominant le fatah de gagner les
élections n'ont pas tellement parce
qu'ils étaient minoritaires mais parce
que ils étaient divisés en plusieurs
listes la liste officielle si je puis
dire une liste dissidente des gens
venant du qatar
avec le soutien de marwan barghouti qui
vous savez déplu à vie en israël
et puis une liste une autre une autre
obédience conduite soutenue par mois m
d'harvard qui est un opposant résolu au
président abbas et qui se trouvent aux
émirats et qui dispose de moyens assez
conséquent bref les élections n'ont pas
eu lieu et c'est dans ce contexte que
les violences sont apparus à jérusalem
en cisjordanie puis à gaza et en israël
je ne veux pas revenir sur tous les
événements jeu mais aussi de demandes
tenir aux têtes de chapitre il ya
d'abord eu vous l'avez évoqué monsieur
le président cette affaire hautement
symbolique crettenand s'il déménage et
fiction de d'habitants de résidents
palestiniens de jérusalem est qui n'ont
pas des habitants des territoires à
lyster bd pas l'islam à jérusalem du
quartier de cheikh jarrah
en réalité il s'agit de quelques maisons
mais c'est une affaire extrêmement
symbolique et très fortement politique
qui s'inscrit dans le cadre de la
politique d'implantation croissante
d'israéliens à jérusalem est
je peux dame où vous dire donc
effectivement elle vous l'avez rappelé
qu'il s'agit d'une affaire qui remonte
avant 48 et que visiblement il y avait
jeudi visiblement parce que tout ça
repose aussi sur des questions de titres
de propriété je parlais trop dans les
détails mais simplement il y avait les
sans doute très probablement des
communautés frappées des résidents juifs
avant la création de l'état d'israël
dans cette partie de jérusalem en 48 des
palestiniens de l'ouest afin de louer ce
débat esthétique qui était dans ce qui
allait devenir l'état d'israël ont été
transférés expulsé et se sont installés
dans ce quartier en jusqu'en 1967
à cette époque la plume m il avait
bénéficié d'un accord conclu entre les
nations unies l'unrra une agence pour
les réfugiés palestiniens et la jordanie
ceci en 1954 leur permettant de
s'installer dans c'est dans ces maisons
en 67 guerre des six jours aux conquêtes
de je ne savais pas par israël la
question se trouve posée différemment et
en 1960
10 israël a voté une loi sur les
affaires juridiques et administratives
qui permet aux citoyens israéliens juifs
de revendiquer des biens perdus en 1948
à jérusalem est
je précise la symétrie la réciproque
n'est pas vraie c'est à dire que des
palestiniens qui avaient perdu leur
propriété à l'ouest de jérusalem ou
ailleurs en israël ne pouvait pas en
réclamer la propriété
bref c'est sur ce set historique que je
pourrai détaillé si vous le souhaitez
qui est intervenu là la mesure d'aider
diction sachant que les tribunaux
israéliens ont nui à plusieurs reprises
à se prononcer soit dans un sens ce soit
dans l'autre sur cette question il est
évident que cette affaire dépasse de
très loin le cadre d'une affaire de
manière privée et qu'elle a eu un fort
retentissement politique puisqu'une même
le président bailly d'elle le premier
ministre le ministre des affaires
étrangères américain longtemps évoquée
soit nommément soit de manière explicite
et qu bien évidemment la france a fait
référence aux nations unies au cas
spécifique de cheikh jarrah
pour l'instant nous sommes dans la tente
dans l'atteinte de procédures juridiques
et nous comprenons de la position
d'abord la communauté internationale des
états unis notamment qui a un appel très
nette aux autorise aux autorités
israéliennes pour ne pas prendre de
mesures unilatérales en suite de cette
affaire
quelques centaines de mètres plus bas
on parle de 500 600 m moins d'un
kilomètre du bar porte de damas à
l'entrée de la vieille ville dans la
partie est de jérusalem en plein pendant
la période du ramadan un certain nombre
d'incidents ce sont produits là aussi
comme souvent ici les choses partent de
quelques de d'événements qui ont une
apparence anecdotique et qui a ensuite
eu un retentissement considérable
de quoi s'agit-il la porte damas est une
des portes de la ville de jérusalem
et à l'entrée de celle-ci se trouve une
sorte de petite faim des entrées en
marche d'escalier un petit peu en forme
d'amphithéâtre sur lesquels la police
israélienne avait installé des barrières
pour éviter les attroupements et c'est à
propos de cette affaire
les barrières que des détentions des
affrontements puis des violences ont
éclaté entre des deux jeunes très jeunes
palestiniens de jérusalem est la police
de reggane l' affaire a pris une telle
ampleur que la police iranienne a décidé
de retirer les barrières ce qui a pesé
les choses mais on a eu quand même
plusieurs mules de très grandes tensions
qui se sont soldés par des blessés des
attaques de part et d'autre et une
effervescence absolument considérable
dans la nounou troisième élément de ceux
de ce scénario de se dérouler de la
violence là aussi il avait évoqué la
planète entière a suivi ce sont les
tensions sur l'esplanade des mosquées
avec des milliers de fidèles musulmans
se sont tombés pendant la plus rama dans
la police israélienne qui monte sur
l'esplanade des échauffourées qui ont eu
lieu des violences y compris à
l'intérieur de la mosquée al aqsa je ne
reviens pas sur tout ce que l'on connaît
je veux juste dire une chose à ce sujet
c'est qu'il faut bien mesurer mais vous
le savez j'imagine que des chaînes
satellitaires des chaînes comme al
jazeera qui touchent des centaines de
millions de gens ont retransmis en
direct pendant des nuits entières les
événements de jérusalem on voyait la
porte damas la mosquée l'esplanade des
mosquées
sheikh jarrah voilà donc je veux dire
que ces images là sont présentes dans
dans l'esprit de millions et de millions
de personnes qui les ont suivis en
direct tous les soirs pendant une
dizaine de jours
quatrième temps gaza le hamas avait
prévu les avait eu israël que si les
tensions continuer de se poursuivre sur
l'esplanade des mosquées
il interviendrait ces menaces ont été
mises à exécution puisque le 10 mai le
hamas à tirer une dizaine de roquettes
en direction de jérusalem
aucune n'est tombée sur jérusalem elles
ont été interceptées une est tombé en
banlieue de jérusalem falloir tout entre
jérusalem est et l'a dit et celle des
tic à partir duquel l'enchaînement cfi
et là on a assisté effectivement un
déferlement de roquettes
plus de 4200 4400 roquettes tirées
depuis la bande de gaza sur au fond le
coeur économique humain démocratique
d'israël
c'est à dire que israël s'il trouvait à
l'aéroport ben gourion compris en
réalité c est sous la menace constante
pendant plusieurs jours et puis comme
tel aviv a vécu à ce rythme pendant
plusieurs jours ce qui naturellement et
c'est bien compréhensible provoquer un
effet de sidération et a entraîné une
aussitôt une la réplique que l'on sait
et cette sidération cas d'une part les
roquettes du hamas ont beaucoup plus
loin que par le passé il semble de sauce
de sources convergentes qu' elle soit
plus puissante qu'elle est une pente et
qui a pu subir plus importante qu'avant
leur nombre exact ne le connais pas mais
on les estime à un ordre de grandeur
allant de 2,15 à famille le rocket et on
considère que le potentiel militaire du
hamas et du jihad islamique qui sont
dans depuis la bande de gaza qui tient
depuis la bande de gaza est
exclusivement depuis la bande de gaza
reste quand même considéra doit rester
quelque chose comme 10 10 à 15000
enquête donc voilà c'est à dire que le
le potentiel n'est pas et loin d'être
décidées il n'est pas du tout voilà il a
été rentable et sans être sans être
décimée
cinquième temps des fêtes important je
ne dis pas que c'est plus important
mercat il est tout à fait significatif
et ils éclairent d'un jour nouveau
les événements la situation actuelle est
peut-être les perspectives à venir
c'est ce qui s'est produit dans les
villes ce qu'on appelle mix en israël
c'est à dire des villes ou des
ressortissants arabes israéliens
coexistant noms importants avec des
citoyens leurs compatriotes israélien je
suis à jeun fort à saint-jean-d'illac à
haïfa
l'option du son
j'ai passive voire vous m'entendez messi
ambassadeur dans ces villes est
essentielle à avoir l'esprit sur les
victimes le bilan même si l'ambassadeur
est ce que vous
il nous a manqué une partie de phrases
et vous étiez justement sur un point
important
donc est-ce que vous pouvez juste nous
leur dire ce qu'il ya une interruption
de la liaison
mais je pense que le cinquième élément
était important
les villes mixtes c'est-à-dire les
villes qui orne israël avec des citoyens
israéliens des citoyens c'est un juif et
des citoyens israéliens arabes sont
parfois tout à fait essentiel car les
tensions qui ont eu lieu et à gaza et
jérusalem est aussi par extension
cisjordanie ont une répercussion
immédiate en israël auprès de la
minorité arabe israélienne 20% la
population des villes comme jafar est
l'ordre à côté de l'aéroport saint jean
d'âcre à l'ifa rabelais et d'autres ont
été le lieu d'affrontements très
violents entre des citoyens israéliens
juifs et arabes et le ministre israélien
de la défense monsieur blanc ce pendant
l'opération militaire israélienne à gaza
a indiqué que ce qui se passait or
israël mène entre les communautés
étaient plus importants même que
l'opération militaire à gaza
et je pense que ceci antilles on est la
personne qu'il était c'est manifestement
de quoi il parlait donc ça c'est une
tendance ou en tout cas un facteur
donc on doit avoir gagné en confiance
pour l'avenir un mot lapidaire mais
malheureusement et bien ça qu on regarde
la souffrance humaine de part et d'autre
vous savez qu'il ya eu à peu près 260
personnes tuées à gaza
70 enfants nous comprenons qu israël
s'est efforcé de cibler ses frappes
pour préserver autant qu'il était
possible la population civile mais enfin
vous savez toujours que dans une
opération de cette nature
la population civile ne peut pas être
épargnée donc il ya comme de nombreuses
victimes sur une opération qui a duré
une dizaine de jours du côté israélien d
honneur du déploré 12 12 personnes tuées
et je crois que ce qui est important
aussi à redire c'est cet effet de
sidération qu'on a vécu ici physiquement
en voyant combien des villes comme tel
aviv ashdod ashkelon enfin le locker est
quand même quand comme ça d'israël était
paralysé pendant plusieurs jours ce qui
bien évidemment a fait mesurer la
fragilité de la situation et peut-être
même la vulnérabilité de celle-ci ce
qu'on peut quand même considérer en
établissant le lien entre les différents
éléments c'est que je vous parlais des
élections palestiniennes qui n'ont pas
eu lieu
des tensions qui ont ensuite éclaté
partout sur cet ensemble
israël palestine ses profondes on peut
considérer de manière paradoxale pour
risquer une formule une jérusalem l'ag
vous allez palestinienne bute certaine
manière n'a pas voté puisque personne
n'a voté mais s'est exprimé ce qui
prouve qui a véritablement à ressorts
humains et politiques très puissant il
est palestinien de jérusalem
je note que les les gens qui sont
descendus dans les rues qui ont
manifesté du côté palestinien car il y
en avait également deux côtés israélien
sont des gens très jeunes on a vu dans
la rue des gens dont des adolescents de
14 ans 15 ans sortir massivement 100
morts
sans être je crois instrumentalisé et
spontanément ce qui en dit long sur la
frustration de cette jeunesse et de
cette population palestinienne dont je
rappelle que même qu'elle représente
enfin les résidents palestiniens
jérusalem 40% de la population de
jérusalem
40% des habitants de jérusalem sont des
résidents palestiniens ont cette grande
municipalité
la deuxième chose
c'est que le gaz gaza la bande de gaza
n'a pas créé non plus bien sûr mais
s'est également exprimé de la manière la
plus puissante et la plus violente
possible et donc là aussi c'est produit
effectivement une expression politique
qui à défaut d'expression démocratique
dans les urnes a abouti à ce déferlement
de violence
quelles sont les conséquences la
première conséquence du côté palestinien
je m'en tiendrai à cela c'est que le
hamas a repris le flambeau et que en
réalité
l'autorité palestinienne a été
marginalisé par à tout ce qui s'est
produit
l'autorité palestinienne au fond a suivi
les événements les a subi plus qu'elle
ne les a menés conduit ont maîtrisé la
deuxième chose c'est qu'on a observés et
ça c'est tout à fait symptomatique une
une forme de deux retours de l'unité
palestinienne de l'unité démographie et
je puis dire c'est à dire à jérusalem en
cisjordanie où il ya eu des mouvements
des tensions les baptêmes de bord
cisjordanie surtout sur des points de
passage des points de contrôle avec de
l'armée israélienne dans la bande de
gaza en israël même je l'évoqué avec ces
manifestations disons que les
palestiniens quelle que soit leur statut
arabes israéliens habitant de gaza
habitants de la cisjordanie résidents
palestiniens de jérusalem est ont réagi
à l'unisson ce qui d'ailleurs comme
aujourd'hui l'indiqué a fait dire au
ministre de la défense israélienne qui
avait là un sujet effectivement de
préoccupation duras ça veut dire que
ceux qui ont assisté et sur le plan
interne et diplomatiquement c'est le
retour de la question palestinienne il y
a je crois une sorte de
deux répliques sismiques inverse aux
quatre années que nous venons de vivre
qui sont celles de l'admission de
l'administration preuve qu'ils avaient
pris à satan d'initiatives en direction
d'israël et de la palestine et de la
région il ya un peu un retour d'une
histoire qui me paraît être un facteur
au front en tout cas ce qu'on peut dire
sans rien préjuger de l'avenir c'est que
la question palestinienne
ce bronze et que la question du conflit
israélo-palestinien presse qu'on le
veuille ou non est peut-être sous une
forme différente que vous voulez vous
qu'ils aient le sud président ouverte
jeu j'ai tendance à penser comme
beaucoup d'autres que dans ce domaine
les idées que d'être trop simple ne sont
pas forcément les meilleurs la france a
eu un rôle majeur
la france salue avant majeur le
président de la république vous savez a
pris des initiatives en coordination
avec nos partenaires égyptiens et
jordaniens que présidence ici pour
oeuvrer en concertation ensuite avec les
états unis avec la communauté
internationale à l'établissement d'un
cessez le feu
je me dis parce que les sommes ne sommes
pas du tout rester inactif la france a
eu un rôle de premier plan en passant
les messages le président république a
appelé le premier ministre netanyahu
comprend une 6 rien il appelait le
président abbas invités retour au calme
et à oeuvrer diplomatiquement en ce sens
les états unis
cris sans doute par l'événement et par
l'enchaînement violences se sont d'une
certaine manière réengager peut-être ça
je ne sais pas mais en tout cas c'est
l'impression que cela donne peut-être
plus vite et plus qu'il ne le souhaitait
initialement
là aussi le président abbas a été le
présent vahid après appelé le président
palestinien une fois pendant trois
quarts d'heure il a les bien évidemment
à plusieurs reprises d'être le premier
ministre israélien le premier le
ministre des affaires étrangères mais
avec un plein coeur
est venu ici et au fond ce que l'on
retient de ce qui nous a été dit par vos
interlocuteurs palestine rc que les
américains veulent maintenant aller de
l'avant en soutenant l'autorité
palestinienne du bar qui reste un acteur
reconnu par la communauté internationale
et quoi qu'on puisse en dire c'est
l'acteur ben le facteur est l'acteur de
stabilité serait engagée financièrement
et trouver les moyens d'aller dans ce
sens vis-à-vis de la vie des
palestiniens et vis-à-vis des offres des
agences des nations unies qui les
soutiennent je pense ici à buras auquel
les américains ont déjà repris après
cinq ans d'interruption
leur versement est ce que cette
situation qui comme toujours ici par
deux facteurs locaux parfois même de
facteurs qui sont d'apparence garde
apparence presque anecdotique et qui
ensuite qu'ils produisent ans et une
déflagration politique et diplomatique
majeur est sécurité est ce que cela peut
avoir des incidences sur des évolutions
on avait noté ces dernières années je
pense aux accords de normalisation entre
israël et a certainement de pays arabes
il est peut-être un peu trop tôt pour
l'affirmer
on peut peut-être on peut sans doute
penser que les fondamentaux de ces
accords de normalisation ne sont pas
remis en question ce qui est certain
c'est que des degrés divers mais du
maroc à aux émirats arabes unis du
bahreïn al arabi qui elle n'a pas
normalisée au koweit et dans l'opinion
arabe
on a vu un raidissement très nette qui
s'est traduit à l'organisation à
l'organisation de la conférence
islamique qui s'est traduit à la réunion
de la ligue arabe
il ya véritablement un lien retour de la
solidarité alors peut être verbale mais
en tout cas assez net vis-à-vis des
palestiniens
et ça c'est un facteur qui change la
donne et qui je le pense mais nous
verrons à l'avenir ce qu'il en est une
fois je ne préjuge rien aura pour effet
quand même de deux modérés ou de
ralentir les mouvements de rapprochement
entre israël et les différents pays qui
est normal c'est que je ne dis pas que
ces accords sont remis en cause
je dis juste qu'il ya un coup de froid
et la question qui est posée
et de savoir s'il s'agit de quelque
chose de temporaire ou au contraire d'un
mouvement plus durable
étant entendu qu'une grande partie de
l'opinion arabe et ceci dans tous les
pays y compris des pays qui ont
normalisé reste fondamentalement
sceptique pour ne pas dire hostile à ses
perspectives
et donc c'est quelque chose dont les
gouvernements ces pays devront tenir
compte
troisième volet je vais aller vite
maintenant quelles sont les perspectives
la première c'est la plus immédiate
c'est la perspective du cessez le feu
le représentant des nations unies pour
le processus de paix m 70 abaissement
norvégien que j'ai rencontré à plusieurs
reprises qui a été reçu à paris
également il ya quelques quelques mois
de cela nous confiant que le csf mieux
cessez-le-feu est fragile
tout le monde en a bien conscience
personne ne veut que la violence repart
personne d'habitude une sim soit de
lancer de nouveaux dégâts depuis gaza
personne ne veut que la population de
gaza et la bande de gaza sera de nouveau
soumise à des bombardements importants
c'est la raison pour laquelle ici même à
jerusalem les autorités israéliennes
font preuve de beaucoup de prudence dans
tout ce qui se passe je pense par
exemple à une marche qui était prévu la
marche de jérusalem qui avaient été
reportées dont le parcours a été a été
dédiée avec des flashs qui réunit des
citoyens israéliens
une marche des drapeaux qui est
l'inspiration un peu similaire doit se
tenir la semaine prochaine la question
de son parcours est posée pour dire les
choses de manière à l'illustré si elle
traverse l'allier ville et les quartiers
musulmans à belleville on craint des
tensions et encore une fois ce sont des
choses comme neige locales et des
facteurs locaux qui sont potentiellement
déclencheur de grandes de grande tension
de fonctionnement
ce à quoi nous sommes confrontés
maintenant c'est la question de la
reconstruction de la bande de gaza bande
de gaza deux millions deux cent mille
habitants jean puis les perspectives à
25 ans et plus de 5 millions d'habitants
donc là on a un sujet majeur dans
l'immédiat ce qu'on entend dire au fond
il ya deux options pour la
reconstruction de la bande de gaza il ya
soit
construction qui se limiterait 6
publiera des considérations humanitaires
au volet humanitaire des nations unies
ont lancé un appel interagences pour
mobiliser 95 millions $ pour répondre
aux besoins immédiats de la population
de gaza qui m'ont d'électricité qui
manquent d'eau et qui dit dans une
situation qui objectivement n'est pas et
ne peut pas être considéré comme
satisfaisant c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
l'egypte joue un rôle majeur elle a
joint aux nageurs je l'évoqué tanner
pour amener le hamas et le jihad
islamique a retrouvé à un vrai en
direction du cessez-le-feu donc elle a
été un intermédiaire situe tout au
passage son rôle qui reste tout à fait
conséquents l'egypte reste un acteur de
tout premier plan sur la bande de gaza
elle a manifesté l'intention de
participer à la reconstruction celle-ci
se pose la question si des moyens
financiers ni par le qatar jusqu'à
présent des sommes considérables qui
permettait à un filet de sécurité social
en quelque sorte dans la bande de gaza
avec des transferts financiers en en
liquide de l'ordre de 20 à 30 millions
d'euros plus les mois depuis des années
ceci bien sûr en accord avec les
autorités israéliennes peut imaginer ce
que les israéliens ne veulent plus c'est
que l'argent de gata puisse être
détourné et servir à mais le hamas
donc la question humanitaire et la
première question immédiat qui se posent
à la reconstruction de la bande de gaza
des objections deux types d objection de
deux natures sont formulées par
différents observateurs par différents
acteurs de terrain qu'ils soient
palestiniens comme le qu'international
la première c'est de dire mais est ce
que on va au contraire gaza où leurs des
molières dans cinq ans ça n'a pas de
sens ni financièrement ni humainement ni
politiquement et la deuxième ce n'est
pas une objection mais c'est une
perspective c'est de considérer que le
problème à gaza mais pas seulement un
problème humanitaire
c'est aussi un problème humanitaire et
c'est d'abord un problème politique
un problème qui est lié au blocus de
gaza depuis quatre ans en est à la
perspective de développer ce territoire
de telle sorte qu'on puisse dans
l'intérêt même de toutes les parties à
commencer par israël à parvenir à à une
cure en stabilité
un territoire le chômage des jeunes est
de l'ordre de 60 à 70 % ou la moitié de
la population n'a pas et en dessous
comme la santé sans emploi ou une grand
partie de la population est tendu du
fait de taux de pauvreté ou la
démographie et ghana porte à l'évidence
ne peut pas être un élément de stabilité
sur la sur la durée donc il ya un vrai
sujet et il ya un sujet politique et le
sentiment que l'on peut avoir c'est
qu'il ya un sujet la politique qui est
adressé à la communauté internationale
dans son ensemble soit on fait de
l'humanitaire ce qui est nécessaire à
très long terme et la france y est prête
et l'a dit l'egypte du nid également
soit on envisage les choses de manière
plus structurelle en quelque sorte pour
voir si et comment il est possible de
trouver des solutions pour une solution
un règlement politique de la situation à
gaza à la fin de cette semaine est
toujours dans cette perspective de
reconstruction de gaza
et d'apaisement des tensions l'egypte
accueille au caire l'ensemble des
factions palestiniennes
les principales d'entre elles le fatah
le hamas ou essayer de trouver les
moyens de s'accorder sur les modalités
d'une reconstruction nous ce que nous
avons eu comme indication de la part de
nos interlocuteurs israéliens
c'est qu'ils sont prêts à aider à cette
démarche mais entendent assurer un
contrôle plus strict des moyens
financiers qui seront acheminées vers la
bande de gaza
la question de l'accès à la bande de
gaza non seulement des personnes mais
également des soutiens des marchandises
et de tout le matériel et l'équipement
des siens au développement est un sujet
vital
l'autre perspective pour les
palestiniens c'est la question de savoir
si compte tenu du fait qu'il n'ya pas eu
d'élection il se lance dans un bus vers
la création d'un gouvernement d'unité
nationale
la question est ouverte au gouvernement
technocrate qui permettrait aux fonds
d'englober toutes les factions sans
véritablement qu'elle soit représentée
dans ce gouvernement
voilà je m'arrête là je pense que j'ai
été trop long je retiens deux idées
c'est que dans cette affaire on a vu la
centralité de jérusalem faire c'est
quand même de jérusalem que son parti
sheikh jarrah la porte de damas
l'esplanade des mosquées
toute cette déflagration et la deuxième
le deuxième point que je retiens c'est
le retour de la question palestinienne
on avait peut-être un peu vite
enterré au cours des années précédentes
voilà monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs dessinateur ce que je vais
vous dire à ce stade
merci monsieur l'ambassadeur de la
présentation très complète que vous nous
avez fait en soulignant bien à la fois
la dimension factuel et puis les
analyses que l'on peut tirer avant de
passer j'ajoute d'entrée de jeu à mes
collègues une question qu'est-ce que si
dimanche soir une nouvelle coalition
domine la knesset avec un nouveau
premier ministre
quels sont les changements qui
pourraient intervenir à la fois dans la
politique de
de notre fin de l'identification de
nouveaux de nouveaux terrains occupés de
nouveaux territoires occupés est ce que
on connaît d'ores et déjà le programme
de monsieur bennett sur ce sujet est ce
qu'il ya une évolution attente qui
pourrait calmer le jeu et où bien est ce
que pour l'instant la coalition n'ayant
pas encore été constituée on n'est pas
très au fait de ce qui risque de se
passer si un départ de monsieur
netanyahou c'est quand même un
changement absolument considérable dans
le paysage régional alors tout à fait
aller alésia lysippe y apprendre à
prendre toute la question mais c'est
pour hausser pour aussi cadre et un
petit peu le débat qu'on va avoir parce
que le changement risque d'intervenir
dans les jours qui viennent je serai
très rapide comme je voulais dit c'est
une question sur laquelle mon collègue
ans adhérente et la liste est plus
légitime que moi réponse que je peux
vous dire c'est que là le caractère
hétéroclite delà de la coalition qui
s'apprête à prendre les rênes vers le
mandat elle amène à considérer que au
fond il va y avoir sans doute mais je
suis preneur dans mon propos un jeu non
pas du tout être catégorique à l'effet
de deux neutralisations interne à dire
qu'il ya des partis
qui sont contre le développement de la
colonisation qui sont favorables des
partis qui étaient favorables à
l'annexion d'appel l'est du jourdain des
partis est un parti islamiste a rappelé
tout ceci pour dire que le pronostic qui
est fait y compris par les observateurs
israéliens tels que je peux lire
elle est consultée c'est que tous ont
font tout ça va ce risque où peut se
neutraliser et que en réalité on sera
peut-être dans une situation de statu
quo je lui avais pris avec prudence mais
c'est la première impression qui ressort
des concertations actuelle merci sans
plus attendre la question de nos
collègues cette intervention
joël guerriau et vous pourrez répondre
collectivement après en fonction des
thèmes qui ont été évoqués par mes
collègues
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le consul général le regain de tension
actuelle entre israël et la palestine a
tweeted plus d'insécurité pour une
ressortissants et vous a évoqué dans
votre intervention el jazeera au niveau
de ses reportages or il se trouve qu el
jazeera il ya trois semaines les bureaux
de jazzera à gaza ont été bombardé par
israël il y avait également d'autres
bureaux d'ailleurs une agence américaine
et israël a affirmé que c'était parce
qu'il y avait un système de brouillage
électronique
est-ce que du hamas est ce que vous avez
d'autres informations sur cette question
où est ce que nous en sommes
et puis enfin la dernière question je
voudrais vous poser très rapidement
c'est que les niveaux de l'influencé des
mollahs sur jérusalem vous dites leur
que j'ai osé même 40% palestiniens dont
je considère que ça doit faire à peu
près 350 mille palestiniens
est-ce que hezbollah
et un duo d'acteurs sur une partie de
cette population est en tout cas qu'en
est il
merci beaucoup en tout cas pour votre
excellente intervention jean marc
todeschini
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur l'ambassadeur mais 2e ce n'est
pas ma question je vais vous lire une
question de notre ami gilbert roger qui
est hospitalisé et qu'il aurait aimé
vous poser certains points ont déjà été
abordées à la fin avril le président de
l'autorité palestinienne mahmoud abbas a
annoncé le report des législatives
on l'a évoqué elle était prévue le 22
mai dernier les dernières ont eu lieu en
2006 ce scrutin avait alimenté une
scission entre le hamas trou dans le
contrôle de la bande de gaza de l'autre
le fatah de mahmoud abbas qui avait
remporté la majorité en cisjordanie
quelles actions la france pourrait-elle
engagé pour aider les palestiniens à
reprendre un truc processus démocratique
lors de votre disposition sur la bassa
d'heure devant le groupe d'amitié france
palestine
le 2 mars dernier vous nous aviez fait
part du sentiment d'abandon de gaza par
la cisjordanie à ramallah
dans ces conditions et alors que les
gouvernements successifs ont échoué à
organiser des élections générales le
rétablissement de l'unité
interpalestinienne vous semble-t-elle
encore possible
quel autre alternative politique est
horrible je vous remercie
merci jean marc qui s'exprimait au nom
de gilbert roger maintenant pascal
allizard oui monsieur le président merci
monsieur le consul général merci pour
cette présentation
moi j'aurai une question plus
particulièrement centrée sur les
élections palestiniennes qui n'ont pas
eu lieu puisque effectivement ça vient
d'être rappelé les dernières datent de
2006 dans un certain nombre d'enceintes
en ce qui me concerne c'est l'assemblée
parlementaire de l'osce et eux nous
avons dû des interlocuteurs palestiniens
jusqu en 2019 et depuis 2010 9 plus
personne plus de contacts plus des
changes et ma question est donc la
suivante
qui dirige effectivement l'état entre
guillemets palestiniens qui représentent
10 qui sont les interlocuteurs officiels
ou pas et en fait quel est leur vraie
légitimité
merci merci pascal pour et les autres
pour ces questions ramasser qui
permettent à chacun de s'exprimer
philippe folliot oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le consul général le
14 mai 2018 les états unis installé
leurs ambassades à jérusalem est ce que
pour vous la nouvelle administration
byden va-t-elle pouvoir changer
fondamentalement les équilibres au sein
d'autres donc de ce cadre très compliqué
des relations israélo-palestiniennes
sans parler du fait de revenir sur ce
choix qui a été fait
contrairement j'allais dire à toutes les
a toutes les décisions y compris de
l'onu donc décisions internationales en
la matière donc est ce que est ce que
vous pensez qu'il pourrait y avoir une
évolution plus équilibrée de la
politique américaine
donc au proche-orient et en ce sens
c'est ce que est ce que la france peut
être un facteur d'accompagnement vous
nous avez dit qu'elle avait joué un rôle
essentiel notamment un lien avec
l'egypte et la jordanie pour le cessez
le feu
mais après pour essayer de revenir vers
ce que je qualifierais comme étant
l'état d'esprit d'oslo pour essayer de
trouver une solution durable
est ce que la france pourra jouer un
rôle aux côtés des états unis à la
matière
merci philippe alors maintenant en visio
pierre laurent ils branchent son micro
bonjour monsieur l'ambassadeur
merci monsieur le président de donner la
parole vous avez beaucoup insisté sur
l'action de la france en faveur du
cessez le feu tout en soulignant sa
fragilité
effectivement le cessez-le-feu était
nécessaire pour éviter l'escaladé
meurtrière qui avait démarré mais elle
n'est en aucun cas une solution puisque
s'il n'y avait que le cessez le feu
le statu quo actuel demeurerait et on
sait que ce statu quo est invivable pour
les palestiniens
donc je crois que là le coeur de la de
la situation reste la situation de déni
de droit que vivent les palestiniens et
comme vous l'avez souligné c'est
effectivement à fait nouveau tous les
palestiniens les palestiniens des
territoires occupés ce que jérusalem est
qu'ils sont victimes d'une politique
d'expropriation et de colonisation
permanente avec toutes les humiliations
vont avec
et puis ceux qui vivent en israël avec
des incidents violents tout à fait
nouveau on vous avait souligné
l'importance et cette situation a été
amplifiée tout ces dernières années par
l'attitude de l'administration trump et
impunité internationale du gouvernement
de netanyahu
alors ma question c'est quelles
initiatives politiques pouvons nous
prendre
ou serait il souhaitable reprendre le
chemin d'une solution politique parce
que le cessez-le-feu
de toute façon ne suffira pas parce que
vous l'avez dit c'est le retour de la
question palestinienne
vous dites que la france agit je dirais
que la france a un grand mérite c'est
qu'elle n'est elle n'a pas quitté ses
positions fondamentales en faveur de la
solution à deux états
et c'est déjà extrêmement important dans
la situation internationale mais la
france agit peu pour une nouvelle
initiative politique
le parlement avait voté une résolution
pour la reconnaissance de l'état
palestinien elle est restée lettre morte
et depuis il n'y a pas eu d'initiative
nous avons attendu pendant des années le
plan américain dont on sait ce qu'il a à
ce qu'il était et aujourd'hui on ne voit
pas venir une initiative politique sur
la solution politique
donc quelles initiatives pourraient être
prises qu'ils soient vus natif de
discussion ou des initiatives de
sanctions notamment contre la
colonisation et enfin ma dernière
remarque concernant les élections
palestiniennes vous soulignez à juste
titre que l'annulation ces élections
étant un gros problème parce que je
crois que la tenue d'élections
palestiniennes serait un des éléments de
la solution politique
la france n'aurait elle pas intérêt dans
ce cadre à agir notamment pour voir
émerger de nouvelles de nouveaux
dirigeants politiques palestinien à agir
pour la libération de marwan barghouti
dont vous avez cité le nom paix qui
pourrait devenir un acteur politique qui
ne laisserait pas le hamas prendre le
flambeau en boule dit merci pierre
françois bonneau
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le consul général
j'aimerais savoir quels quel regard vous
portez sur le sur la démocratie
israélienne je veux dire par là que la
difficulté pour pour ce pays a dégagé
une majorité et le fait que
quelques députés qui parfois ne
représente loin s'en faut la la majorité
de l'opinion du pays se permettre
d'obtenir des décisions
qui effectivement
de par leur poids et parce qu'ils sont
pas en capacité de faire basculer un
gouvernement et est ronde et rendre
effective
effectivement la situation complexe mais
j'aimerais avoir votre votre regard sur
cette situation et et tous les tous les
remous que ça provoque un pays merci
françois alain houpert
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
consul général benjamin netanyahu a fait
contre l' épidémie de kovy de la
vaccination son cheval de bataille voir
un argument politique du likoud jeu ma
question sera très courte il ya une
différence entre deux populations la
population israélienne et la population
palestinienne j'aimerais savoir si les
ratios de vaccination sont égaux dans
les deux populations
merci merci enfin olivier cigolotti
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
consul général
les etats unis ont appelé au
cessez-le-feu au même titre que l'egypte
le qatar la jordanie et bien d'autres
pays
mais dans le même temps refusé
l'intervention du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu alors présidé par par la chine
cette situation est quelque peu
paradoxale se poser la question du rôle
de la chine c'est peut-être sous-estimé
le rôle qu'elle joue dans cette région
du moyen-orient
ma question est simple est-ce que le
gouvernement de pékin entretient des
relations suivies avec israël et l'état
palestinien
et est ce que l'on peut désormais
considérer que la chine est le nouveau
poids lourd diplomatique dans cette
région du moyen-orient merci monsieur le
consul général
voilà alors une dernière intervention
michel gréaume merci monsieur le
président voilà même si on parle on
parle aujourd'hui du départ éventuel de
benjamin netanyahu
la plainte sur les crimes de guerre et
sur les crimes contre l'humanité c'est
également sur le ministre de la défense
et ministre des affaires étrangères
qu'elles aient adressé cette plainte
alors ne croyez vous pas que la france
doit prendre ses responsabilités et ses
responsabilités et peut-être continuer à
exiger la pro de la protection du peuple
palestinien merci voilà monsieur
l'ambassadeur en faisant de questions
complémentaires merci
donc si vous m'entendez bien parce que
toute petite coupure à un moment je
verrai plus j'ai su répondre à
différentes questions
je vais les prendre dans l'or sachant
qu'à sont toutes complémentaires la
question je crois que monsieur je n'ai
pas noté de monsieur joël guerriau c'est
cela oui ces jeunes guerriau d'accord
sur le bureau d'al jazira le bureau d'al
jazeera et de l' agence américaine à
société de presse on était dans un
bâtiment qui était détruit à gaza
ça a été nous n'avons pas d'indication
particulière sur ce sur cette affaire
enfin plus que tout ce qui est sur la
place publique
ce que je peux dire c'est d'une part que
et que la société de presse et el
jazeera se sont retrouvés à la rue le
bureau de l' agence france-presse
à gaza a accueilli ses deux confrères
dans l'eure dans leurs bureaux ce qu'on
peut quand même observer c'est que du
côté alors pas sur al jazeera mathieu
associés presse évidemment ça aucun émoi
considérable aux états unis le
secrétaire d'état américain aux affaires
étrangères a appelé aussitôt après le
président de la chance de presse
et évidemment ça je ne sais pas si cela
a contribué à accélérer la leur et
l'engagement américain
je dis juste que dans l'opinion
américaine c'est un facteur qui a été
quand même
important mais je n'ai pas d'indication
spécifique sur la destruction ce
bâtiment si c'est effectivement ce que
l'on ce que l'on pensait tous les
arguments qui ont été mis en avoir parlé
céréalière pour le visent et indiquant
qu'il y avait un plan de renseignement
du hamas à faire de ce bâtiment ce qui
est possible mais très honnêtement je ne
le sais pas le niveau de présence ou
d'influencé du hezbollah jérusalem
honnêtement il y en a vraiment en ce
sens que le hezbollah comme vous le
savez est un mouvement libanais et pas
un mouvement palestinien
de surcroît cette manche il alors que
les palestiniens sont sunnites et que
s'agissant de une représentation
politique de lys clanisme que ça soit le
hezbollah au liban qu'ils s'agissent de
la au liban en palestine ce mouvement
porte un nom principal c'est le hamas
donc non il n'y a pas une influence
directe du hezbollah à à jérusalem ni
dans les territoires palestiniens
il peut y avoir peut-être de la
sympathie dans une partie de l'opinion
publique palestinienne à l'égard du
hezbollah n'est pas véritablement la
question sur le s bonheur c'était savoir
si hélas se reposer pour les militaires
majeures c'est si pendant qu'ils avaient
depuis le sud des roquettes qui ont été
tirées par milliers depuis la bande de
gaza sur israël si le hezbollah avait
fait la même chose depuis le nord c'est
à dire depuis liban là on arrêtait
véritablement dans une configuration
d'une tout autre nature
monsieur le sénateur et des sit in y
vous avez posé une question pour le
compte de dix sénateurs gilbert roger
auquel je souhaite un prompt
rétablissement
est ce que le processus électoral peut
reprendre que peut faire la france
il peut reprendre nous souhaitons qu'il
reprenne il faut tenir quand même con de
la conjoncture dont je parlais dans mon
exposé liminaire c'est à dire que le
rapport de force actuellement est plutôt
favorable est même nettement favorable
après ce qu'on me dit oh wow hamas il
est certain que le renouvellement
démocratique est une condition
et la légitimité de l'autorité
palestinienne et de la stabilité de
l'ensemble régional l'unité
palestinienne
les élections devaient y conduire c'est
à dire au fond réconcilier le fatah et
le hamas récit la bande de gaza et la
cisjordanie et permettre et permettre à
l'autorité palestinienne et peut-être
que la reconstruction de la bande de
gaza y contribuera de reprendre pied
dans la bande de gaza qui comme vous le
savez est contrôlé depuis 2006 2007 par
le hamas
monsieur le sénateur à lisa vous avez
posé la question au fond très directe de
savoir qui est que représente l'autorité
palestinienne sachant que vous n'avez
même plus depuis 2009 de contact avec
des parlementaires palestiniens n'a plus
parlement politique qui décide
la réponse c'est le président abbas avec
quelques collaborateurs et ils procèdent
par décret je représente l'autorité
palestinienne pour la communauté
internationale et pour la france
l'interlocuteur officiel et légitimes
des palestiniens
elle est censée préfigurer le futur état
palestinien dans la perspective des
états en interne
parlons clair la légitimité de
l'autorité palestinienne s'érode et ceci
pour deux raisons d'abord parce qu'elle
n'est pas appuyé par un soutien
électorat d'où la nécessité d' élections
et puis parce qu'au fond son rôle se
réduit de plus en plus à faux à faire la
coordination avec israël en matière de
sécurité en matière d'affaires civiles
voient la table la question de la
légitimité de l'autorité palestinienne
aux yeux de l'opinion palestinienne est
posée
monsieur le sénateur philippe folliot
vous avez posé la question au fond de la
présence américaine et de l'évolution de
la position des états unis
le président bailly donne maintien
l'ambassade américaine à jérusalem
en revanche le secrétaire d'état aux
affaires étrangères le ministre oublie
qu'elle a dit a annoncé aux palestiniens
et publiquement que les états unis
envisageaient la possible afin pas
envisagé d'annoncer l'intention des
etats-unis devrait ouvrir leur consulat
général à jérusalem qui aura entre
autres missions d'après ce que je
comprends celle d'assurer la relation
politique avec l'autorité palestinienne
donc oui des l'évolution ça c'est très
net je pense que cette évolution s'est
accélérée à la faveur de la crise e du
mois dernier et maintenant les
américains sont clairement dans une
dynamique tendance à reprendre langue et
reprendre l'opération à reprendre une
présentation sous une forme qui reste à
préciser
les rebonds relations diplomatiques avec
les palestiniens
et de ce point de vue là il ya un
changement de cap est passé assez assez
nette
et est ce que la france peut facteurs
d'accompagnement je ne sais pas ce qui
est certain c'est que les positions de
l'administration payday sont plus
conformes à ce qu'aimer droit
international lacasse pectives d'une
solution à deux états et cet égard elle
se rapproche considérablement de la
position européenne
faut pas exagérer l'impact immédiat mais
enfin l'évolution est quand même là et
elle est nette
monsieur le sénateur pierre laurent vous
êtes revenu sur la question du cessez le
feu et très honnêtement ce que vous
dites me paraît très juste le
cessez-le-feu est fragile
chacun en convient et en tout état de
cause le cessez-le-feu par lui même
n'est pas une solution et il est une
réponse immédiate et une réponse
nécessaire mais il n'est pas une
solution politique durable
bien évidemment les positions de la
france exprimée au plus haut niveau de
l'état par halloween ça les affaires
étrangères sont connus nous restons
fidèles à la perspective des deux états
et vous avez rappelé opportunément que
la france tient ses positions
ça peut peut être paraître un peu
statique à certains en réalité je pense
que ça n'est pas du tout
et que c'est qu'une une fermeté
diplomatique
rappel des principes
ces dernières deux dernières semaines
ont montré c'est qu'en réalité on ne
fait pas on ne fera pas l'économie d'un
règlement juste et du conflit israélo
palestinien
on avait un peu dit enterré le conflit
israélo palestinien on avait peut-être
un publi de côté la question
palestinienne à proprement parler mais
cette question reste entière et ceux qui
en ont pleinement conscience je crois ce
sont les dirigeants israéliens surtout
après ce qu'il s'est passé
une fois la semaine les semaines des
systèmes dernière est évidemment comme
vous disiez il et on peut penser
rationnellement que des élections
palestiniennes contribuerait apporter
une bouffée d'oxygène démocratique à la
population palestinienne jeanne qui a
envie de se prononcer qui forme et qui
souhaitent comme tous les peuples du
monde pouvoir choisir ses dirigeants
peut-être même renouveler le personnel
politique et dans ce contexte la figure
de marwan barghouti qui encore une fois
jeudi était plus à vie en israël et donc
on avait pressenti en faudrait plus que
passante y compris qu'il serait candidat
à une élection présidentielle et qu'ils
vont ils auraient pu gagner cette
élection présidentielle évidemment à
tout ça a confié en importance
voilà sur la question du sénateur
françois bonneau s'agissant de la
démocratie israélienne
là encore une fois je suis prudent je ne
suis pas directement des relations avec
israël
oui il n'y a pas de majorité où il ya
des majorités très compliqué à trouver 7
6 en mode de scrutin car je le rappelais
au début qui est à la proportionnelle
intégrale et on aboutit effectivement à
des majorités extrêmement hétérogène
comme celle qui va visiblement le libyen
visiblement attendons dimanche se
constituer avec un gouvernement qui
réunit des forces politiques qui sont
sur des sensibilités très très écartés
très différentes les unes des autres
monsieur le sénateur alain houpert vous
a posé la question de la vaccination la
vaccination en israël a été un succès
le gouvernement a acheté massivement des
vaccins files heures et d'ici quelques
semaines c'est à dire sans doute de la
fin du mois de juin
on peut penser que 65 à 70% de la
population israélienne sera vacciné ce
qui veut dire qu'on claire l'épidémie
sera ici derrière nous il n'invente pas
vrai pour les palestiniens pour
lesquelles la vaccination progresse et
pour lesquels les situations qui sont
variables les résidents palestiniens de
jérusalem est sont vaccinés comme tous
les règnes les travailleurs les cent
quarante mille travailleurs palestiniens
de cisjordanie qui se rendent tous les
jours en israël pour travailler sont
également vaccinés la vaccination
progresse avec l'achat et la fourniture
de vaccins différents un peu de files
heures astrazeneca les vaccins rustre
des vaccins chinois dans les territoires
palestiniens
mais en l'état un taux qui est inférieur
on est plutôt à un taux de l'ordre de
30% et la situation est encore plus
compliquée dans la bande de gaza ou
alors même que y compris en cisjordanie
l'épidémie temps à ceux à se ralentir
dans la bande de gaza nous ne sommes pas
encore tiré d'affaires loin de là ce qui
protège la bande de gaza en réalité
c'est la jeunesse de sa population qui
la préserve élimine israël qu sorte les
effets négatifs du vin des conséquences
du coc vite même s'il ya eu des décès à
déplorer
monsieur le sénateur audi liessies
galletti vous avez souligné la
différence qui avait entre l'action
diplomatique des américains qui a
accompagné le mouvement que la france a
ouvert à me dire qu'à chronologiquement
parlant avec ses partenaires égyptiens
jordaniens en faveur du cessez le feu et
une position non plus
gardez au conseil de sécurité c'est vrai
effectivement il a fallu là aussi
beaucoup travaillé avec les américains
pour arriver finalement les résolutions
du conseil de sécurité qui vous savez a
finalement été adopté donc ça c'est une
chose de fait importante et la chine
comme président du conseil de sécurité à
jouer tout son rôle et effectivement
elle a joué un rôle accru accru par
rapport peut être au passé est ce que la
chine est un poids lourd diplomatique au
proche orient
honnêtement je ne crois pas encore
mais ce qui est certain c'est que la
chine ayant une vocation de puissance
globale et elle en a les moyens
elle ne pourra pas faire l'économie de
s'intéresser à ce qui se passe au proche
orient
elle a de bonnes relations avec israël
elle a des projets industriels des
projets économiques des projets
d'investissement d'israël
elle veut aussi cultiver sa relation
historique avec des bastidiens et jouer
des acteurs de premier plan nous ne
ressent pas encore tout à fait là très
honnêtement et enfin je termine pas la
question
deux sénateurs michel grémeaux je crois
sur la question de madame grès ou sur la
question de la protection du peuple
palestinien
vous savez la question du peuple
palestinien la protection du peuple
haïtien c'est un sujet important c'est
un sujet majeur
vous avez d'abord les agences des
nations unies humanitaire aide aux
réfugiés palestiniens qui s'en occupe
toute la communauté internationale la
france est extrêmement actif dans ce
sens là nous coopérons avec les
palestiniens nous avons eu l humanité n
est pas destiné un soutien budgétaire à
l'autorité palestinienne
nous sommes au plus près des populations
palestiniennes je rappelle que l' agence
française de développement est
extrêmement active dans les territoires
palestiniens avec des projets
structurants je vais prendre
illustration
s'il ya de l'eau et c'est un parfait
dans la bande de gaza s'est très
largement grâce à l'action de l'agencé
française de développement et d'autres
bailleurs internationaux
voilà un exemple très concret bien
évidemment l'inscription est loin d'être
parfaite
et la question que vous posez est une
question strictement importante qui sur
laquelle nous travaillons je pense
collectivement l'union européenne ya
comme une intention la france au
quotidien
voilà j'ai essayé de répondre monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs à vos différentes questions
est ce que monsieur le président si vous
m'autorisez parce que vous aviez dit
dans votre propos introductif que la
france a des domaines nationale si oui
nous avons le conseil général gère pour
le compte de l'état quatre domaines
nationaux dont trois domaines avec des
communautés catholiques ici à jérusalem
elles sont l'objet de toute notre
attention car nous sommes en situation
de fragilité d'incertitude et nous
apportons tout soutien à ces communautés
et nous sommes restés en contact avec
toutes les communautés qui sont sous
notre protection légale pendant la
période de tension pour nous assurer
qu'il n'y avait pas eu de violence à
leur encontre
c'est même si certaines étaient placés
dans des quartiers très très tendue et
évidemment la sécurité de nos
ressortissants français
nous avons 45 mille concitoyens qui
habite sa circonscription de jérusalem
très grande majorité sont des
ressortissants des compatriotes seront
prises ride c'est nous avons des bien
sûr quelques quelques ressortissants
dans la bande de gaza qui sont des
binationaux quelques ressortissants dans
la cisjordanie en cisjordanie et puis
bien sûr déjà noté m
mais là la sécurité de nos concitoyens
mot nationaux binationaux a été au coeur
de notre préoccupation et nous les avons
immédiatement contacté dès les tirs de
roquettes sur j'aime célèbre ceci pour
nous assurer que les choses étaient bien
je dirais que c'est surtout sans contact
et avec nos concitoyens et bien
évidemment en lien et en pronation
étroit avec le quai d'orsay
voilà ce que je pouvais dire de manière
imparfaite mais en essayant de répondre
du mieux que je le couvert aux
différentes questions monsieur
l'ambassadeur vous avez parfaitement
répondu à
à toutes nos questions et vous n'avez
fait que susciter plus d'intérêt encore
à ce sujet je vous rappelle faisant
allusion en cela aa neuronaux entretien
récent lorsque nous étions venus ici à
paris que le sénat si la commission des
affaires étrangères a inscrit à son
ordre du jour
une mission qui réunirent est du reste
les présidents de groupe au sein de
cette commission pour une mission à la
fois israël territoires palestiniens
donc je vous serais reconnaissant le
moment venu quand vous considérez que la
situation est apaisée étant à la fois
sur le plan de la sécurité que sur le
plan politique et qu'on puisse avoir un
certain nombre de contacts intéressants
vous me direz à kehl dans quelle
échéance
on peut commencer à travailler sur la
préparation de cette mission j'imagine
que si c'est le cas ce serait plutôt à
l'automne
mais comme nous avions déjà reculé cette
ce déplacement il ya un an
nous aimerions bien néanmoins pouvoir la
montée avec votre appui je sais que
cette visite sera particulièrement
passionnante parce que vous avez vous
êtes un poste à la fois d'action et
d'observations et de contact qui nous
permettra de nourrir notre réflexion
donc vous nous direz j'imagine le moment
venu pour qu'on se met tant qu'on se
prépare sylvie permettez monsieur le
président je peux d'ores et déjà vous
faire part de mon rôle de ma première
impression
je pense que cette mission si elle peut
se faire cette année c'est à dire à
l'automne ce sera une excellente chose
je pense de cette mission sera
extrêmement utile pour des raisons qui
tiennent aux vies depuis quand suite aux
événements récents nous n'avons pas eu
de visite politique c'est-à-dire
ministériel ou parlementaire depuis
maintenant plus d'un an et demi donc
vraiment si on sera extrêmement utile et
après quelques apostrophes d'ici là si
la situation monétaire reste comment
dirais-je un peu près stable je pense
que la situation sanitaire sera
surmontée et je pense que l'automne sur
une des excellentes un excellent créneau
pour que vous veniez et nous serons
vraiment à votre entière disposition
pour monter cette mission notamment du
côté palestinien et à jérusalem très
bien hébert va prendre je prends bonne
note je prouve notre monsieur jean
bassères de ces indications va se mettre
en route pour préparer ce déplacement
merci encore infiniment et vous avez
bien évidemment le soutien amical et
fervent de la commission car vous êtes
une fois de plus dans un poste délicat
compliqué mais
là les éléments que vous nous avez
fourni montre que vous représentez avec
toute votre équipe
la france avec compétence avec brio vous
en remercie sont des postes vraiment
difficile et on a besoin de talents
comme le vôtre pour que le drapeau
français flotte car c'est une région qui
a été toujours au coeur de deux de nos
gouvernements successifs et il ya tant
de liens qui nous unissent avec tous ces
pays et le travail que vous y faites est
vraiment extraordinaire donc soyez
assurés de notre confiance et de notre
soutien
merci monsieur l'ambassadeur merci
beaucoup je suis très sensible
vous allez monsieur merci merci
infiniment merci et à très bientôt
[Musique]